the ab world's poorest country the war
in Yemen has basically been a stalemate
for the last six years how old are you
15 years old you're 13 years old and you
want to fight Yemen is in the midst of
the world's worst humanitarian crisis
are hard to come by Health Facilities
run on limited power
media host now from time to time we go
ahead and talk about the injustices that
are happening in different parts of the
world and usually when we touch upon an
injustice in this part of the world and
people are like why are you not talking
about this part of the world then we
talk about this part of the world
because it's just happening all over the
place Muslims are some of the most
suppressed people in the world and you
have all of this going on and there's
little to no media attention on it so we
want to do our small part and create
awareness to what's going on in Yemen
and who better yet to talk about this
than our next guest
we'll be right back we need to do this
for the future of our children the
future of our great country the future
of mankind this is your brother and I've
got a very important message
alhamdulillah our brother Eddie is
setting up the dean Center not just the
dean show but the dean Center a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it foreign
[Music]
and like I mentioned in the opening you
know we talk about the different
oppression is going on in the Muslim
world and people have been asking what
about Yemen why haven't you talked about
Yemen we got an opportunity now what's
going on in Yemen
well if you look throughout the world a
lot of challenges a lot of travel areas
a lot of hot spots
and one of the areas is Yemen Yemen
according to the UN is considered the
worst humanitarian crisis in the world
repeat that according to the United
United Nations Yemen considered the
worst humanitarian crisis in the world
why doesn't the world talk about this
thing
I'm not sure why the world is not
talking about it but a lot of people
dying worse than Ukraine
it is worse than you so it's worse than
Ukraine but the whole world's talking
about Ukraine just just imagine
for example 80 percent
of the population which is like 24
million live on assistance
imagine four million people Plus
they are internally displaced idps or
refugees within their own countries
just think about it that
1.2 million orphans in Yemen children
that father or lost their mother or lost
their parents
the half of the school system
or half of the health industry is not
function anymore
and the sad part when we say the worst
humanitarian crosses in the world the
sad part every 10 minutes A Child die in
Yemen
lack of food starvation
and lack of medical care every 10
minutes every 10 minutes
so it is a tragedy unfortunately is not
picking up
the media supposed to pick up
even the funds supposed to be coming
from the United Nations not even half of
it is coming to Yemen so we rely on
people like you
non-profit organizations good people
throughout the world to come and give a
hand to the yemeni people subhanallah so
tell me now is there any campaign like
pray for Yemen like you have prayed for
Ukraine and again we don't take away
from the suffering in Ukraine or
anywhere but it seems like this was
happening far before anything was
happening in Ukraine just for example
I'm just giving an example but do we see
this trending at all do we see this
since almost something goes on in these
places is like pray for Ukraine pray for
this prayer but is there any pray for
Yemen like when the whole world is
collaborating now and coming together to
help the situation Yemen I think
somewhere around 2000 we never hear this
in the news 2014 sometime at pickup in
the news
but most of the time is not there but as
people of the world as Muslims what news
it picked up on CNN sometime on National
use but it is not there all the time so
it's like any other tragedy it hit the
waves for some time then it dies
so now it's not much in the media but we
as people were trying to create
that voice for those who do not have
voice
we pray to them in every daily prayer we
ask people throughout the world to pray
for the people of Yemen and everywhere
where people are suffering Muslims and
non-muslims we care about people and we
rely on our Lord Allah to alleviate
their suffering so we do prayers prayers
by itself is not going to work you need
to accompany it with some actions yes
sir so can you give us an example of the
day-to-day life for a yemeny's family
you know I I had a a person call me from
Nashville Tennessee
they have a village
and it's like two miles
they need to run water from one place to
another throughout the mountain
to get to their Village the project is
around forty two thousand dollars
they have managed to get the pump they
have managed to get the solar system and
now they're just trying to get the it
and imagine every day you have to walk
two miles and this is a close
area you know it's not too far you have
to walk two miles fill up gallons of
water and go up into the mountain
to have water for your tea or for you
gotta walk two miles you have to this is
a small walk actually in Yemen people
sometimes they have walk more than that
to get to water
imagine a child
does not have shoes
to ear
one when our president went to Yemen our
chairman of the organization pure hands
he said
there was a child and he was crying next
to his mom
and he asked why he's crying what does
he need he said he just want to be in
the classroom with his
friends
imagine you know today I was reading in
the report for the Yuan
and they were saying that
Yemen at the brink of losing an entire
generation imagine a child since 2014
until today
you're talking about eight nine years
did not go to school
so if somebody is the first grade today
at that time now is the ninth grade
doesn't know the alphabet doesn't know
how to multiply numbers
doesn't know anything around him what is
the future hold for them
many kids unfortunately
became victims of the wars and at the
young age being used also in the
battlefield unfortunately it's very sad
when you as a parent
you have nothing to offer your kids to
eat how you feel
when you as a parent
doesn't have money to buy your kids some
clothes to wear how you feel
when you see your child malnutrition
they're losing their life in front of
your own eyes
very simple eye surgery five hundred
dollars the cataract
thousands people could see just with a
small operation it's not available it's
very tough do you get exasperated when
you see people complaining about the the
latest shoes or maybe the latest outfit
and sometimes you have even husband and
wife you know bickering over stuff that
now like we don't have the latest
gadgets maybe the latest car but then
maybe they come to you because you're
sure also and they're in front of you
presenting cases and stuff and it's
monetary you know what I mean Dunya
stuff and then do you ever share some of
these experiences you know I I was given
a photo yesterday in San Luis yeah and
part of my hotel is you know as an
immigrant I came to this country
uh to New York probably have a few
hundred dollars with me
I know a friend or not and not much
and we started from zero got nothing on
us
today alhamdulillah many of us in the
similar situation
we get homes we have cars we have family
we have children we have jobs we have
income coming on a daily basis so I told
the people we need to always
appreciate what Allah had given us
is the son of the Prophet salallahu
always when it comes to Dunya and life
and materials look at the people below
you because you will feel the suffering
if you look up you're going to break
your neck you're not getting there and
you feel bad so we need to appreciate
the blessing of Allah in all of us our
health our families meeting people like
you having a show like this create
awareness about our Muslim ummah some
time we focus on this Dunya and we
forget that the very Basics we have you
know if you look in the convention today
and and you see how many bottles of
water have empty and thrown here and
there people would love to have that sip
of water in Yemen forty dollars it's
provide water for a family for the whole
month in Yemen when it comes to that so
we're spoiled especially here in this
country Allah blessed us and blessed us
a lot so we need to be thankful first to
Allah
and we need to be thankful by sharing
this blessing with those who are
unfortunate absolutely so how can people
share the blessings how can people get
involved to go ahead and make some kind
of difference
I always say
you know
for any action we do in life
when we work as a team when we talk as a
group
when we work as a group it makes more
sense and I give example of the Prophet
saws he was traveling
and the companions want to you know be
kind to him they want to provide food
for him so one of the companies said you
know I have a sheep I want to slaughter
it for you so you can eat the other
companion said you know what I can skin
it for you
third one he said I'm a good cook I'll
cook it for you
the prophet did not sit down and wait
for the companion to compete who will
serve the process and he said
in the prophet of Allah I will go and
collect the sticks so I can light the
fire
if each one of us
feel that responsibility that when I see
my brothers and my sisters whether it's
in Yemen or Raza or in Pakistan today
with the flood or anywhere in the world
or here in New York or Chicago if I see
somebody in need
what can I do I might not be able to
solve the world problem
but I can
solve somebody problem
and
our teaching of our Prophet salallahu is
amazing
because he does not want us to look at
the needy as burden
he wants us to look at him as an
opportunity for us
he said if you are able to bring a
happiness
somebody
Allah God will not reward you with
anything but the Jannah
but the paradise
if you bring a smile that's your ticket
to Paradise who are the most beloved
people to Allah he said those who are
beneficial to others
what is the most beloved deed Allah
loved the most he said a a happiness you
bring to somebody
so I think always we need to have that
attitude what can I do to help others
says the relationship between us
our Brotherhood our Sisterhood the the
community the the the community together
is like the relationship between the
hands and the eyes now you ask me how
you know if the eye cries and the tears
come down
the hand will wipe out right
and if you have pain in your hand what
happened the tears will come down
that is our relationship as one body it
doesn't matter you're in in China and in
your in in America everywhere
human needs are human needs Muslim and
non-muslims we all in in the same boat
so let's look at ourselves and see what
I can do as a person we often respond to
relief organization we often respond to
to a certain needs okay if we can take
it a further step where I as a person I
will look and see the needs of others
not respond to their need let me see
where the needs is sometimes my need is
in a Masjid sometimes I need an Islamic
school sometimes my need is like a
project you're purchasing sometimes the
need is is helping the people in in
Pakistan or in Yemen or somewhere let's
first step have that attitude in
ourselves that let me be part of the
solution as much as I can now we can
talk about how to do it but if we have
that attitude
that I care and I want to help
he used to borrow money he till people
go buy credit on my account and when I
have it I will pay he will never turn
somebody away and our people in Yemen
and elsewhere they're crying for our
help
how can people help very simple you know
for example I'm with pure hands and
we're focusing
mainly on Yemen and we've been serving
the yemeni community for the last 10
years and alhamdulillah with people like
you and donors from different parts of
the US we were able to provide that on
three-handed Millions worth of
assistance to the people of Yemen and we
touch the heart of 5 million people
this cause is bigger than all of us but
we're focusing on on strategic areas
that impact the life of the people
number one we have uh the food security
a lot of people as I said especially in
villages and remote area they have
nothing to eat so we provide a food
basket hundred ten dollars hundred
dollars a month can provide for a family
of seven for 30 days imagine you know
that's a blessing so food security is
one area wash which is water either we
dig water wells or we provide
monthly water delivery to these people
or sometimes we have tanks of water
delivered to a certain area then we have
also Health whether providing some
clinics or dialysis for kidneys or
providing medical or medicine
for the people or doing some minor
surgeries we have also some programs
protection for the children which is
related to the orphans then we have
shelters we build houses for those who
are stranded and we have livelihood
programs that try to give the people a
heads up and help them live their life
instead of just receiving assistance and
that's a pure hands that is pure hand
and our heart is connected and I'll
reward you for your work thank you so
much we appreciate your time and effort
thank you
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in and see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum